WELCOME BACK DRIVEN TAX
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY WOULD
YOU LIKE TO OPEN UP TO. WELL
WE'RE STARTING AT THE
SUBCOMMITTEE. HAPPY NEW YEAR
EVERYBODY. WELL THANK YOU FOR
GIVING ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT THIS BILL I'M PROUD TO
PRESENT AB EIGHT FIFTY WHICH
CREATES A LOAN REPAYMENT
PROGRAM FOR CHILD WELFARE
WORKERS CURRENTLY THERE'S A AN
EXTREMELY HIGH TURNOVER RATE
FOR CHILD WELFARE WORKERS
WITHIN THE STATE AND ESPECIALLY
WITHIN THE FIRST THREE YEARS OF
ENTERING THE WORKFORCE. THERE
ARE NUMBER FACTORS CONTRIBUTE
TO THIS SUCH A STRESS COURSE
LONG HOURS AND INCREASED
CASELOADS. CHILD WELFARE
WORKERS ARE AMONG THE LOWEST
PAID SOCIAL WORKERS EVEN THOUGH
THE ACCOUNT FOR NEARLY HALF OF
ALL CHILD FAMILY AND SCHOOL
SOCIAL WORKERS IN THE STATE.
NEARLY HALF THE WORKFORCE IS
OVER THE AGE OF FORTY. AND THE
DIVERSE COMPOSITION OF CHILDREN
IN THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM DOES
NOT REFLECT. THAT OF THE
WORKFORCE. THIS PROFESSION
NEEDS DIVERSITY AND YOUNGER
STAFF TO EFFECTIVELY ADDRESS
ISSUES IT'LL COMMUNITIES. AB
EIGHT FIFTY ADDRESSES THESE
ISSUES BY CREATING A SYSTEM FOR
CHILD WERE FOR WORKERS WHERE
UPON THE COMPLETION OF THREE
YEARS THE STATE WILL PAY 50% OF
THE REMAINING DEBT. FOR THOSE
WHO RECEIVED THEIR BACHELOR'S
OR MASTER'S DEGREE IN SOCIAL
WORK. THIS BILL IS A FORCE OR
THE LA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS.
THE COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA. AND
CAL SWC. WITH ME TODAY TO
TESTIFY AS REBEKAH GONZALEZ
WITH THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS. RIGHT
CHARRON MEMBERS MY NAME IS
REBECCA GONZALEZ I'M I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER WE'RE A
PROFESSIONAL ASSOCIATION THAT
REPRESENTS APPROXIMATELY TEN
THOUSAND SOCIAL WORKERS WITH
THEIR BACHELOR'S OR THEIR
MASTER'S DEGREE IN SOCIAL WORK
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL I
WANT TO THANK THE MEMBER FOR
INTRODUCING AT- TOO GREAT A
LOAN REPAYMENT PROGRAM- AS- WAS
ALLUDED TO- STUDENT LOANS ARE A
TO TERROR AND FOR DIVERSITY AND
LONG TERM RETENTION. THE MEAN
SALARY FOR ALL THE WELFARE
WORKERS IS FORTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND THE MEANS STUDENT
LOAN DEBT RANGES FROM THIRTY
TWO THOUSAND TO FORTY TWO
THOUSAND THE PRESSURE OF MAKING
ENDS MEET WITH LOW SALARIES AND
HIGH INTEREST RATE IS CAUSING
COLLEGE GRADUATES TO PURSUE
MORE LUCRATIVE CAREERS.
CONSEQUENTLY THIS REALLY
NEGATIVELY IMPACTS CHILDREN WHO
WERE IN THE SYSTEM- THAT
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT THE
NATIONAL ANNUAL TURNOVER RATE
IN CHILD WELFARE IS 20% IN
PUBLIC AGENCIES AND 40% AND
PRIVATE AGENCIES. WHEN A CHILD
WORKER. BEES WITHIN THE FIRST
THREE YEARS THAT IT MUST HAVE.
HE TO UNDER PERCENT OF THE
EXIST EMPLOYEES ANNUAL SALARY
FOR HIRING AND TRAINING NEW
STAFF THIS IS UNFORTUNATE AS I
MENTIONED BECAUSE CHILDREN
GOING THROUGH THE SYSTEM
BENEFIT FROM CONSISTENCY
CONSISTENCY WITH THEIR CARE
GIVERS AND CONSISTENCY WITH
THEIR SOCIAL WORKERS. THE
PROGRAM IS IMPORTANT FOR OUR
PROFESSION BECAUSE STUDENT LOAN
BURDENS CAN DISCOURAGE THE
PURSUIT OF SOCIAL WORK CAREERS
AND MAKE IT DIFFICULT FOR
SOCIAL WORKERS WITH STUDENT
LOANS TO REACH SIGNIFICANT
FINANCIAL NOT MILESTONES LIKE
PURCHASING A HOME OR SAVING FOR
RETIREMENT. A MATCH LEARN ABOUT
A MASTER'S OR BACHELOR'S DEGREE
IN SOCIAL WORK IS THE GOLD
STANDARD FOR CHILD WELFARE
WORKERS THE SOCIAL WORK
CURRICULUM AND STANDARDS
REQUIRE A WORKING KNOWLEDGE OF
CHILD AND ADULT DEVELOPMENT.
THE IMPACT OF TRAUMA PARENTING
AND FAMILY DYNAMICS AND
COMMUNITY SYSTEMS WHERE THE
CHILD AND FAMILY RESIDE. IN
ADDITION SOCIAL WORKERS AND
CHILD WELFARE SHALL HAVE A
PROVEN ABILITY TO APPLY THIS
KNOWLEDGE TO APPROPRIATELY
INTERVIEW CONTENT PRESS THE
NEEDS OF CHILDREN AND FAMILY.
IN ORDER TO PREVENT HARM TO THE
TILE AND MAXIMIZE THE FAMILY'S
CHANCES FOR POSITIVE
FUNCTIONING AND STABILITY FOR
ALL THESE REASONS JURAI VOTE.
SO WHAT ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
FOR. DON'T BE SCARED THE REALLY
NICE THE FIRST PART RIGHT MY
NAME IS KINDER BARNES AND A
MASTER'S STUDENT AT SAN JOSE
STATE UNIVERSITY AND I SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. MY NAME
IS LUCRETIA THOMPSON AND I'M A
STUDENT AT NORTHRIDGE MASTERS
SOCIAL WORK AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK. ARE THE GUERRERO
REPRESENTED THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
ALSO SOCIAL WORKER VERY GOOD
BILL WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU. HELLO. YOU CAN
FINANCE OKAY I AM T<c.cyan> AM A</c>
GRAD STUDENT I GO TO CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY NORTHRIDGE
THANK YOU. ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE OF WITH MIA COMMENTS
QUESTIONS ARE MADE OUT QUIRK SO
THERE'S NO DOUBT THAT. DON'T
LOOK BAD ON HAPPY TARA YOU'RE
LOOKING VERY UNHAPPY. I'M READY
OKAY. THE LIKE SFETY I KNOW
I'M READY THE FTV IS HERE I
WANTED TO ASK THEM THEY'RE
ESTIMATING THE REVENUE LOSS OF
NINETY THOUSAND A HUNDRED
THOUSAND SIXTY THOUSAND. THAT'S
LIKE TO LOANS. THIS IS IN-
FISCAL YEAR IS- THIS YEAR NEXT
YEAR THE YEAR AFTER AND. IT'S
LIKE YOU KNOW WHO'S GOING TO
CLAIM IT AND WHAT THE- HOW MUCH
THEY'RE GOING TO CLAIM
CERTAINLY THEY'RE GOING TO BE.
I WOULD IMAGINE DOZENS OF
PEOPLE WHO WOULD CLAIM UNDER
THE S. AND SO I DON'T SEE HOW
THE NUMBERS CAN BE THIS LOW.
GOOD QUESTION MEMBER QUIRK. MY
LIFE. OKAY THANK YOU IT'S BEEN
AWHILE SINCE I'VE BEEN UP HERE
AT JENNA CARLSON ASSISTANT
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD HAPPY NEW
YEAR AND ONLY YOU. I'VE IT'S
INTERESTING THERE WAS A LOT OF
HAIR CUTS TO GET DOWN TO WHAT
SEEMS TO BE A VERY LOW-
UNUSUALLY LOW AMOUNT. OUR DATA
IS BASED ON INFORMATION FROM
THE BUREAU OF LABOR STATISTICS
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND THE
NATIONAL US DISSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS. AND ONE THING
THAT REALLY LIMITS THAT FIRST
POPULATION IS THE REQUIREMENT
FOR LEGIBILITY IS THAT YOU HAVE
BEEN EMPLOYED FOR THREE YEARS
SO THERE'S THAT TRIGGERING
EVENT. AND WHAT WE HAVE IS
THAT- THERE ARE. APPROXIMATELY
THREE THOUSAND- CALIFORNIA
CHILD WILL FORCE WELFARE SOCIAL
WORKERS WITH EITHER A MESS
BACHELOR'S OR MASTER'S DEGREE
IN SOCIAL WORK FOR TAX YEAR TWO
TWENTY TWENTY. AND THAT 10% OR
THREE HUNDRED OF THOSE WORKERS
WOULD HAVE BEEN EMPLOYED BY
EITHER STATE OR COUNTY AND
WOULD HAVE MET THAT. TRIGGERING
DATE SO THAT'S WHAT'S REALLY
LIMITING THE AMOUNT OF.
300-004-0000 DOLLARS A LOT MORE
THAN THE NUMBERS YOU HAVE HERE
TRUE AND IT IS A 50% AWARD SO
THAT AGAIN IS A FURTHER HAIR
CUT AND ALSO WITH THE STUDENT
AID DATA THAT WE WERE ABLE TO
FIND BASED ON A REMAINING
STUDENT LOAN PRINCIPLE AFTER
THE THREE YEAR PERIOD WE WERE
LOOKING AT ONLY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS SO ONLY A THREE MILLION
DOLLAR. OVERALL RIGHT AND THEN
YOU HAVE THAT 250% AND YOU GET
THREE MILLION. RIGHT AND BUT
THEN WE ARE ALSO EXCLUDING FROM
INCOME AS OPPOSED TO EVER
INCLUDING IN INCOME SO THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT YOU WANT. THIS
IS AN INCOME EXCLUSION. SO DOES
NOT ON THE TAX RETURN DIRECTLY.
OKAY BUT IT'S STILL GONNA COST
IS THREE MILLION DOLLARS. IN
I'M NO AT A 6% TAX RATE- AND
BAY- IT'S- I'M SORRY IT'S NOT
CLOSE THROUGH THE TAX RETURN
RIGHT IT'S NOT JUST A STRAIGHT
THREE MILLION. OKAY IT'S ONLY
6% OF THAT OF WHATEVER THE
TAXES DO SO EVEN THE THREE
MILLION MAY NOT ACTUALLY HAVE
BEEN ALL TAXABLE IF IT WERE
OTHERWISE INCLUDED IN INCOME
BECAUSE OF OTHER DEDUCTIONS ARE
OFFSETS THAT A STUDENT MAY HAVE.
YOU'RE GRANTING THEM THREE
MILLION DOLLARS RIGHT. WE
BELIEVE SO WHY ISN'T THE COST
THREE MILLION DOLLARS BUT THE
COST ON THE TAXES SO IT'S THREE
MILLION OUT OF THE GENERAL FUND
AND THAT'S WHY YOU DIDN'T
INCLUDE IT. NO IT'S THE THREE
MILLION IS APPLIED THERE'S A AN
AVERAGE TAX RATE THAT IS
APPLIED. AND THAT IS WHAT THE
DIFFERENCE TO THE GENERAL FUND
WOULD BE. 6% OF THREE MILLION.
OKAY HEY OKAY AYE AYE AYE ALL
RIGHT LOOSES AGAIN AS IT RUNS
THROUGH THE TAX RETURN AND
THERE'S OTHER DEDUCTIONS OR
EXEMPTIONS EXCLUSIONS THAT
SOMEONE MAY BE ELIGIBLE FOR
THAT ALSO COMES INTO PLAY IN
THE FINAL NUMBER. I'M SO GLAD
SHE'S HERE. I'M SORRY I DIDN'T
QUITE HEAR YOU. ALL RIGHT.
YOU'RE REWARDING THREE MILLION
DOLLARS WE BELIEVE SO. AT
THIRTY GETTING AWAY CORRECT WE
HAVE ASSUME YES IT'LL BE FULLY
FUNDED AND THAT WOULD BE THE
FUNDED HOWSAM ON THAT COULD BE
GRANTED OKAY BUT HOW IS IT
FULLY FUNDED. THAT IS A
FUNCTION OF THE BILL. OR STAND
IT WOULD NEED APPROPRIATIONS
HELP IT'S NOT FUNDED THROUGH
THE BUDGET IT DOES THE BILL
DOESN'T DO ANYTHING RIGHT.
CORRECT I SEE ALL RIGHT. THAT'S
WHY THE NUMBERS SO LOW. DOES
COME INTO PLAY YEAH IT IT IT
HAS TO BE FUNDED THROUGH THE
BUDGET ALL RIGHT NOW I
UNDERSTAND. SO IT'S THREE
MILLION DOLLARS IF IT'S FUNDED
THROUGH THE BUDGET AND IT'S
NEXT TO NOTHING OTHERWISE. OKAY
NOW I UNDERSTAND OF. SO I JUST
TO BRING AND THEN ONE OTHER
POINT THAT'S BROUGHT UP IN THE
ANALYSIS IS. V. E. ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE FACT THAT
IT'LL BE FEDERALLY TAXED. I
SINCE IT'S A GRANT IT'S INCOME.
AND SO THAT. PERSON WHO GOT
THIS MONEY WOULD HAVE TO PAY
WHATEVER THEIR FEDERAL TAX
AMOUNT IS ON THAT AMOUNT
BECAUSE RATHER THE LOAN
FORGIVENESS IT TO GRANT SO IT'S
INCOME. ARM AND- THEIR WAYS TO
GET AROUND THAT BUT- I CAN SEE
WHY YOU CAN'T NECESSARILY PUT
IN THE BILL DO YOU HAVE ANY
COMMENT ON THAT DOOR FOR
WORKING THROUGH SOME OF THESE
COMPLEXITIES BUT WE THINK
THEY'RE ALL WORKABLE. OKAY.
THEN MY FINAL QUESTION IS. YOU
KNOW I KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF
BURN OUT. BUT IF WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO. IS PROMOTE PEOPLE
TO STAY WHY IS IT THREE YEARS.
THAT'S THE AVERAGE. TIME THE
MOST THE PEOPLE ARE LEAVING AS
YEAH I'D SO WHY NOT MAKE IT
FIVE YEARS TO AT LEAST KEEP
THEM AROUND A COUPLE MORE YEARS
THE POINT IS YOU'RE NOT GIVING
IT YOUR SPENDING THREE MILLION
DOLLARS BUT YOU'RE NOT
NECESSARILY GETTING ANYTHING
FOR IT. IF PEOPLE ARE TYPICALLY
SPENDING THREE YEARS ALREADY
WHY NOT THEN YOU KNOW DO
SOMETHING SO THOSE STAY A BIT
LONGER. SO THE POINT IS YOU
NEED MORE SOCIAL WORKERS THERE
TYPICALLY LEAVING AFTER THREE
YEARS. IF YOU KEEP THIS. TIME
PERIOD IS THREE YEARS THEN HOW
ARE YOU GOING TO ENCOURAGE
PEOPLE TO STAY A LONGER PERIOD
OF TIME. WHY NOT MAKE IT FIVE
YEARS AND THEN YOU AT LEAST GET
A COUPLE EXTRA YEARS OUT OF IT
THAT'S CLEARLY AN ALTERNATE
PERSPECTIVE BUT I WOULD SAY
THAT WE WANT TO GET ON WITH
THEIR MOST VULNERABLE PERIOD
WHICH IS PROVEN TO BE THREE
YEAR. I DON'T UNDERSTAND
BECAUSE YEAH PLEASE IF I COULD
ADD SOMETHING THAT GO WITH THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS THERE'S ALSO ANOTHER
PROGRAM THAT HELPS PEOPLE WHILE
THEY'RE IN SCHOOL IF THEY-
AGREE IT'S CALLED THE TITLE FOR
YOU PROGRAM IF THEY DOES IF
THEY PROMISE TO MAKE A TWO YEAR
COMMITMENT IN THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM WHEN THEY GRADUATE SO WE
DO FIND A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
LEAVING AFTER TWO YEARS I THINK
THREE YEAR IS A MARK BUT THAT
TWO YEARS IS A HUGE MARK ALSO
SO. I THINK THAT- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHOOSING THE THREE YEAR
TIME FRAME MAKES SENSE OKAY.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
COMMENTS QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. SEEING NONE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LIKE WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. I WOULD JUST
TELL YOU IN MY DISTRICT THE
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM TRULY
NEEDS HELP WHAT WE ARE PROBABLY
THE- I THINK ONE OF THE MOST
CHALLENGE DISTRICTS IN THE
ENTIRE STATE WITH THIS
PARTICULAR PROBLEM WE'VE HAD A
LOT OF TRAGEDY. AND A HIGH
TURNOVER RATE IS REALLY AN
ORDERLY IMPACT IN MY DISTRICT
AND SO WE REALLY WANT TO
PROVIDE A REMEDY. TO MAKE SURE
THAT. WE ADDRESS THESE ISSUES
THAT I TALKED ABOUT IN MY
OPENING STATEMENT SO WE WOULD
APPRECIATE AN AYE VOTE WHEN
AND- WHEN WE GET THERE. THANK
YOU FOR TESTIMONY ONLY BUT WE
HAVE A QUORUM SO WE'D LIKE THIS
HIGHLY CALDERON. KIRK HERE
ROBERT. TO THEIR GRAY. MAYES
MELENDEZ MULLIN PETRIE-NORRIS.
QUIRK HERE RIVAS. TING THE BILL
WHICH ACCORDING. WE HAVE A
QUORUM THANK YOU MISTER VICE
CHAIR
. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS HAPPY NEW YEAR.
AB FIVE THIRTY FIVE WILL
INCREASE THE AMOUNT OF LICENSE
MENTAL HEALTH AND HOUSING
PROFESSIONALS IN CALIFORNIA BY
PROVIDING THESE INDIVIDUALS A
TAX CREDIT FOR INITIAL
LICENSING FEES ACCORDING TO THE
LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION ONE
FIVE CALIFORNIANS MUST RECEIVE
PERMISSION FROM THE GOVERNMENT
TO WORK LICENSING FEES IN
CALIFORNIA FOR NEW PROFESSIONAL
STARTING A CAREER MAKING A
CAREER CHANGE REQUIRES THESE
INDIVIDUALS GOING TO THAT.
BEFORE THEY CAN EVEN GET A JOB
FOR LOWER INCOME LYSONS
OCCUPATIONS IN CALIFORNIA
APPLICANTS ON AVERAGE PAY THREE
HUNDRED DOLLARS IN LICENSING
FEES SPEND FIVE HUNDRED FORTY
NINE DAYS IN EDUCATION AND
TRAINING AND MUST PASS AN
EXAMINATION A LICENSING FEES
FROM AND HEALTH PROFESSIONALS
IN CALIFORNIA CAN RANGE FROM
TWO HUNDRED. TO SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY DOLLARS IS FOR HOUSING
PROFESSIONALS THREE HUNDRED
FIVE. FIVE THIRTY DOLLARS. THE
LICENSING IMPORTANT CONSUMER
PROTECTION HOWEVER NISH
LICENSING FEES ARE VERY TO
ENTRY FOR THESE PROFESSIONALS.
CALIFORNIA'S HAD A LONG HISTORY
OF BEING BAD FOR BUSINESS.
COMPARED THE REST A NATION WE
RANK THIRTY SECOND FOR AN
OVERALL BUSINESS CLIMATE FORTY
THIRD FOR COSTS. IN FORTY EIGHT
FOR BUSINESS TAXES LET'S
REVERSE THAT TREND LET'S. STAND
UP FOR JOBS BY KNOCKING DOWN
BARRIERS TO ENTRY SING CURRENCY
MORE PROFESSIONALS SUIT PURSUE
WORKING CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
AND RESPECT LAST YEAR VOTE WHEN
IT'S ON. THANK YOU WHEN THIS IS
IN SUPPORT. WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE THAT WORK. BALLOT YOU
YOU AND I HAVE SERVED ON THIS
COMMITTEE TOGETHER A LONG TIME
SO YOU KNOW WHAT MY FIRST
QUESTION IS A HIS ARM I WOULD
PREFER A REFUNDABLE TAX CREDIT.
WHICH WENT TO THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE NOT PAYING TAXES AS OPPOSED
TO THE MORE WEALTHY PEOPLE WHO
ARE PAYING TAXES AND SO THAT'S-
ALWAYS MY NUMBER ONE CONCERN
WITH ANY TAX DEDUCTION. ARM THE
SECOND POURING POINT IS. WELL
WHAT DO YOU WANT TO WELL WHY
DON'T YOU ARE WELL ANYONE TO
THAT WHEN THE MAIN THING IS
WE'RE TRYING TO GET PEOPLE TO
GO ON THESE PROFESSIONS WE HAVE
A HUGE HOMELESSNESS CRISIS IN
CALIFORNIA AND WE DON'T HAVE
THE FACILITIES OR THE
PROFESSIONALS TO TREAT THESE
PEOPLE AND- IT'S JUST LIKE IF
YOU LOOK AT THE JOB WE NEED
TRUCK DRIVERS WE NEED PLUMBERS-
WE NEED NOT OF PROFESSIONALS WE
NEED ENGINEERS- AND THERE'S
BEEN OTHER PROGRAMS FOR NURSES
TO PAY OFF A BUNCH OF PEOPLE TO
GO INTO NURSING. YOU KNOW
PEOPLE JOIN THE MILLER. GI BILL.
AGAINST PEOPLE TO GO INTO THE
SESSIONS THAT WE NEED CURRENTLY
AND THIS IS JUST. WE CAN DEBATE
THE- THE TAX BENEFITS FROM ONE
CLASS OR ANOTHER BUT THIS BILL
IS MAINLY TO TRY TO GET PEOPLE
TO. ENROLL IN MENTAL HEALTH
EDUCATION AND GOING TO THAT HIS
PROFESSION RIGHT IN AND MY
CONCERN IS THAT IT'S GOING TO
THE WRONG PEOPLE NOT THE PEOPLE
WHO NEED. THE HELP THE MOST.
BUT TO PEOPLE WHO CAN ALREADY
AFFORD TO PAY TAXES ON A TAX
RELIEF THIS IS JUST IF YOU IF
YOUR LICENSING FEE FOR THE
FIRST YEAR OF FIVE HUNDRED. AND
I BELIEVE WE MAY HAPPEN IN
THAT. THROUGH THE AIR. YOU GET
YOUR FIRST WAVE TO THE BOX. SO
IT'S A LICENSING FEE REDUCTION-
IT'S A LICENSING FEE REDUCTION
YEAH ALL RIGHT CELLS THAT'S NOT
THE WAY I READ IT I RATED EASY
IT'S EASING THE LICENSING FEE
FOR PEOPLE WHO A TAX CREDIT.
BUT IT'S NOT A REFUNDABLE TAX
CREDIT. WE HAVE THAT. RIGHT OR
THE STANDARD TAX CREDIT. SO HI.
NO I UNDERSTAND THAT NO MIKE MY
CONCERN IS NOT A REFUNDABLE TAX
CREDIT SO THAT THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE LOWEST ON THE INCOME SCALE
GET NO BALLOT AND WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO IS WE- WERE TRYING
TO REDUCE THE LICENSING FEE. I
KNOW BUT PEOPLE WHO NEED THE
HELP THE MOST ARE GETTING. YEAH
I. BUT YOU KNOW WE'VE HEARD ME
SAY THIS SHADOW YEARS SALE BUT
YOU KNOW IF YOU'RE A
MILLIONAIRE YOU'RE PROBABLY NOT
GOING INTO THE MENTAL HEALTH
FIELD TO BE HONEST WITH YOU. WE
MIGHT BE GOING. STATE WHATEVER
YEAH BUT I MEAN WE'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT MILLIONAIRES BUT
AT ANY RATE. UP THE OTHER
CONCERN IS WHY THESE
PARTICULAR- PEOPLE WHY REAL
ESTATE WHITE NURSING WHICH YOU
SAID ALREADY HAS OTHER
PROGRAMS. WHY DID YOU
PARTICULARLY PICKED THE SAP A
CONTRACTOR STATE LICENSING
BOARD WHY DID YOU PARTICULARLY
PICKED THESE. BECAUSE IF YOU
LOOK AT THE JOB DEMANDS IN
CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW ITS TRUCK
DRIVERS IT'S- PLUMBERS. IT'S
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS
THESE ARE THE YOU KNOW IT'S-
ENGINEERS- WE NEED PEOPLE TO GO
IN THESE INDUSTRIES FOR THE
FUTURE CALIFORNIA SO THEY'RE
NOT ON YOUR LIST. UNION HAVE
ENGINEERING HERE YOU DON'T HAVE.
I TAKE ON ALL THE INDUSTRIES OF
JUST. THE ONES YOU JUST
MENTIONED ARE NOT PART OF THE
LIST ALL RIGHT. THAT'S FINE. I
WILL JUST LEAVE IT AT THAT
THANKS THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FOR THE
COMMITTEE. I THINK YOU KNOW
DOCTOR PARKS POINTS THAT I
THINK HE MAKES A REGULARLY OR
HEAR ENOUGH TO KNOW WHAT TEN
AND ALL THE OTHER THING TOO IS
YOU KNOW WHAT I HAD MY FIRST
MEETING IN THE OFFICE BEFORE I
EVEN GOT INTO THE OFFICE AND IT
WAS ENROLLED AGENTS WHO ARE
HERE TALKING ABOUT SERVICE
TAXES AND I THINK. PART OF THAT
WAS TO GET THE WHOLE
CONVERSATION. STE CONVERSATION
ABOUT BUDGET REFER. AND BE.
RELY ON PERSONALLY TAX INCOME
THAT. BALANCING OUT THE
MOUNTAINS AND TROUGHS IN. YOU
KNOW. YOU'VE GOT. A COUPLE OF
MISTER QUIRK IN MR TANG NUMBERS
COMMITTEE BEEN HERE A TERM
BEFORE ME. AND WE CNTINUE TO
TALK ABOUT THAT BUT I THINK-
SINCE THAT MACRO BUDGET PROCESS
REFORM HAS NOT BEEN. TACKLED
YET YOU KNOW SOME OF US STILL
TRY TO GO ABOUT THE ANYTHING
EVEN WHEN GOVERNOR BROWN WAS
AND HE WOULD GIVE THESE VETO
MESSAGE THIS ISN'T THE BEST WAY
TO DO THE BUDGET. BUT IT IS
WHAT IT IS AND SOME OF US TRY
TO WORK THROUGH THE PROCESS TO.
GET SOME CREDIT SIR. OR SOME
TREES. I THINK YOU. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSER WITH MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE AS MUCH I
PLAYING I WAS CLOSE ALL RIGHT I
TESTIMONY ONLY TODAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU MEMBERS ALL RIGHT
WITH. WE ARE ADJOURNED